- Welcome back, y'all.
You might remember this story we featured
on the show last season.
Students in an Atlanta
elementary school were asked
to dress as their favorite hero.
This is so cool.
A young boy named Luke chose
his teacher, Mr. Freeman.
Luke said his teacher
is a hero to every kid
because he's kind and thoughtful.
So let's look back.
- I'm the only Black male
teacher at my school out
of 54 teachers.
- Wow.
- So for him to see himself in me,
it really was special for me.
- He's inspiring, kind,
funny, brave, and I thought
it'd make him happy.
- Oh my gosh, that's so sweet.
- Have over 20 years
of experience teaching,
and I was gonna leave
the field of education.
I was gonna go into medical sales.
I had already said that
year five, I'm leaving.
But that wasn't my gift.
My wife said to me, "Your gift is kids."
(audience applauds)
- Here's where it gets really amazing.
A grandmother in Virginia
watched that episode
and wondered if Mr. Freeman
could help her grandson.
So she tracked him down
and what happened next
changed all of their lives.
It's an incredible story in
what we call Best In Class.
(upbeat music)
♪ Best in class ♪
- Please welcome back to
the show, Mr. Freeman,
along with Denita, the grandmother
who reached out to him.
(audience cheers)
So let's, welcome to the show,
first of all.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
- What struck you about Mr. Freeman?
- Watching that episode and I saw,
first I heard that Mr.
Freeman was the only
Black male teacher in the whole school.
However, this young boy,
who happened to be white,
saw something in him that
compelled him to become the hero,
for him to dress like him for that day.
- Yeah.
- It just made me know
that he can reach children
in a different way.
That meant so much to me.
I had to reach out to Mr. Freeman.
I had to find him
because I wanted to talk to
him about my own grandson.
- Yeah. So what was Tre
like before Mr. Freeman?
- So, Tre, Tre I think
is the best human being.
I love him so much.
But Tre is a very, he was
quiet, kind of withdrawn.
Tre didn't do a lot, like with friends,
or he wasn't outgoing.
- Mm-hmm.
- And he was in the fifth grade,
the last year of elementary school,
and he was about to go to middle school.
And I was kind of concerned
because I wanted him to be able to fit in-
- And middle school is hard.
- In middle school.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So that is why I reached out,
because I just wanted to, I
thought I was getting pointers,
some tips, you know, how to speak to him,
how to do things differently,
but not with Joe Freeman,
because Joe Freeman, he went all the way.
He gave me the phone number
and this was on a Tuesday.
So your show was on a Monday.
Because the very same day
that I watched the show,
I wrote the email.
And on that Tuesday, he reached out,
and he has been calling Tre
every Tuesday for a year, so.
- Wow, the consistency.
(audience applauds)
What have you noticed about Tre?
Ever since working with him?
- Oh my God,
the changes in Tre are amazing.
Tre has a lot of friends now.
Tre, he used to.
(audience applauds)
- So cute!
- Yeah.
So that is actually a picture of,
Mr. Freeman went to Mexico
and he had on this cool outfit.
- Mr. Freeman probably had a good time.
- And Tre loved Mr.
Freeman's outfit in Mexico.
And next thing I know, Tre got the outfit.
- Aw, oh, that's so nice.
- Yeah, so.
- You've given him confidence.
- Yeah.
- Self confidence.
- So Tre had, at the
end of the school year,
elementary school, entered a rap battle,
which I would've never thought
he would do.
- Yeah, you thought
he'd been too shy.
- Yeah, he entered
the rap battle and won third place.
- Wow.
(audience applauds)
He had a lot to say.
- He did.
- He was just keeping it
to himself.
- And he couldn't wait
to share his information.
Everything he does, he can't
wait to tell Mr. Freeman.
So it is amazing.
- Man, that's so cool.
- And and this is our first time.
This is our first time meeting.
- I've never met him before.
- I've never met her.
I've never met her, yeah.
- Everything has been over the phone.
So I'm so super excited.
I've never met him before
and Tre has never met him.
- Yeah. Tre's never met.
- That's what I wanted say.
So here's the deal, Tre has never met him,
and they've been talking for a year.
- Almost a year.
- By the way,
the consistency, man,
that's the coolest thing
that you can provide a kid.
So thank you for that.
- Yeah.
- Consistency is so amazing.
(audience applauds)
But Tre thinks that he's here
to talk about his schoolwork.
He has no idea Mr. Freeman is here.
So we're going to have Mr. Freeman hide.
You don't wanna miss the surprise.
I don't either, stay right here.
Tre is here today. Give it up a Tre.
(audience cheers)
Look at that smile.
- So Tre, how do you think Mr. Freeman
has kind of impacted your life?
How has he affected you?
- I'm lucky that Mr. Freeman as my mentor.
- Yeah.
- He calls me every Tuesday.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you look forward to that?
- Yes.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
So I heard that you had your
first dance this weekend.
Is that true?
- Yes.
- Do you like dancing?
I love dancing.
I mean, I will just dance
just right here for you.
I love dancing.
- Well it depends what song they play.
- Exactly. It's gotta be a good DJ.
We have an amazing DJ here,
Reuben. I'm just saying.
He plays amazing music. So.
(audience applauds)
I agree.
It does depend on the song,
but we love teachers on this show.
My mama was a teacher, so I
always try and lift up teachers
and just recognize how angelic they are.
So what do you wanna say to Mr. Freeman?
- He changed our lives and
thank you for everything.
- Aw.
(audience applauds)
Those are powerful words.
Well, I have some good news,
'cause you can tell him that yourself.
He's actually here. Come
on out, Mr. Freeman!
(audience cheers)
- What's up big way Tre, what's up?
How you doing?
- I'm good!
- Oh my God!
- Give me a hug, yeah?
You thought that I was shorter?
- Y'all wanna scoot and
then we'll sit, yeah?
- There you go, just sit here.
- Oh my gosh.
What do you wanna say to Tre?
First of all, this is a big thing to like,
speak on a show like this,
man, you're doing well.
- First of all, I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of you for coming
to a new city, another state,
for even taking a chance to talk to me.
The first thing he said to me,
"I thought you were shorter." (laughs)
So over the phone,
we've never had FaceTime anything,
so he just sees pictures,
so I guess, yeah.
- Oh wow.
- You look a lot taller right now.
You look a lot taller.
- That's amazing.
- I'm just proud of you,
man. I'm proud of you.
I'm proud of the things you've been doing.
I'm proud of the things you've done.
- How does this
relationship make you feel?
This is amazing, this is
all from you being affected,
watching something, then
you actually acted on it,
by the way.
- I did act on it,
and I got so much more
than I ever expected.
I'm just overwhelmed because
(audience applauds)
not only is he there for Tre,
he's become family.
And we talk about everything, we talk,
as well as them talking.
So we talk about everything I know,
about graduations or going to college,
buying a new house, eating crabs.
I mean, we talk about everything.
So it really is a family,
I think, on both sides, so.
- I think it's so good too to have people
outside your family to
have those relationships
with as well, because you might
open up in a different way.
So I think this is so special. So cool.
- Yes, I do too.
And I just want to thank Mr. Denita.
You know, Miss Denita,
I just want you to know
that I appreciate you
and I'm forever grateful
to be a part of your family.
And the loving on him
allowed me to love on him
too, and I thank you for that.
- Wow. Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Well, before we go, we
wanted to ask about Luke,
Mr. Freeman's student who was here before,
also known as Sir Luke.
How's Luke doing,
- [Joe] Sir Luke's doing amazing.
Sir Luke, that's my guy.
He comes, so Luke, that's him,
me giving him the book for the first time.
- Yeah.
- His first time seeing it.
I mentioned it on the show
that he was gonna be a
character in the book.
Sir Luke's in the book,
he has on the same suit
that he had on, that we
were on the show with.
He's signing autographs.
Anytime he's in my classroom,
he's signing autographs,
he's high fiving kids in the hall.
He's in fourth grade now.
So Luke's doing great.
He's another example of confidence,
how believing in a child can really-
- Change the trajectory.
- Yes.
- Absolutely.
(audience applauds)
Well, I love this whole story,
but I'm hardly the only one.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate the
powerful connection between
Denita, Mr. Freeman, and Tre.
So they're giving Tre $5,000.
- Whoa!
(audience cheers)
- That sound all right?
- Wow, thank you. Thank you.
- Yes!
- Wow, thank you.
Thank you.
- Oh my God.
Have some fun. Do something fun with that.
- Wow.
- Well, thank y'all
for coming on this show.
- How do you feel?
- How does that feel?
- I can go to college.
- Oh my God.
(audience applauds)
I love you so much that
that's where your brain went.
If you ever need any extra
help on that, you let me know.
I will always help with education.
Oh my gosh. We need a
short break everybody.
We'll be right back with What I'm Liking.
Doesn't, what a!
(audience cheers)